la libye fait un pas déterminant vers la
paix après cinq jours de négociations à
genève sous l'égide de l'onu les
représentants du gouvernement d'union
nationale et ceux de l'autorité de l'est
en trouver un terrain d'entente
les deux parties en conflit depuis 2015
ont signé un cessez le feu concernant la
totalité du territoire libyen est à
effet immédiat
l'accord prévoit la création d'une force
commune entre les deux camps pour faire
respecter l'arrêt des combats
l'accord créé une salle commune des
opérations de police qui proposera et
appliquera des dispositions spéciales
pour sécuriser les zones débarrasser des
unités militaires et des groupes armés
la commission militaire conjointe a
également accepté de former une force
militaire conjointe limité de personnel
militaire régulier sous une salle
d'opération conjointe relevant de la
commission militaire conjointe
le traité prévoit également le départ de
tous les mercenaires engagés en libye
malgré l'avancée des discussions les
acteurs internationaux restent prudents
et doute même de la viabilité de cet
accord l'accord de cessez le feu de ce
jour n'a pas été conclue au plus haut
niveau mais à un niveau moindre
pour moi cet accord semble manquer de
crédibilité
nous savons très bien que la mise en
oeuvre sera plus difficile que les
négociations sur cet accord
quand les conditions seront réunies nous
donnerons suite à nos engagements
il ne faut pas aller plus vite que la
musique il faut attendre
l'espoir d'une paix durable reste encore
fragile dans un pays plongé dans le
chaos depuis neuf ans et la chute du
gouvernement de mouammar kadhafi les
combats ont fait des centaines de morts
et poussé à la fuite des dizaines de
milliers de personnes